I built my name's dangles and my
question is how do you reach someone who
is maybe a conspiracy theorist or
someone who is anti vaccines someone who
is staunchly scientifical scientifically
illiterate and agree with them on what a
good source effects is thank you so
Daniel how do i how do I recommend
reasoning with a conspiracy theorist I'm
right now the last couple months I've
been messing around with this idea of
cognitive dissonance this is to say you
have a worldview you're presented with
evidence that conflicts with the
worldview so you either have to change
your worldview which is hard because
you've lived your whole life with it or
you just dismiss the evidence and
dismiss the authorities that may have
provided the evidence the authority
could be a person or it could be a book
or excuse me an article in the on the
electric internet computer machine just
so you dismiss the evidence so that you
don't have this discomfort this conflict
in your mind this dissonance that's what
I'm working with right now apparently
the way to overcome that is to say we're
all in this together let's learn about
this together present the conspiracy
theorists with the idea that he or she
may be rejecting evidence because it's
just so uncomfortable that and you're in
it together we're going to I'm
uncomfortable too but when it comes to
moon landings just ask the person how
you would generate all that paperwork
the warehouse is full of documentation
that National Nessa
created to make landings on the moon
would overwhelm any anybody trying to do
it on the side you just be very
difficult to print all that and just
understand it's a process somebody who
has a worldview that's inconsistent with
evidence and I may have some it takes a
while for you to turn around like the
example of palm reading or astrology
it's not something people reverse their
ideas about immediately
it takes in my experience takes about
two years for somebody to sort of look
at palm-reading
look at cold reading or a tarot card
reading for a while and then realize
that these tarot card readers palm
readers are just taking information that
you've given them the clients given them
and feeding it back to you takes a long
time in the same way people who who are
anti-vaccine I think have just lost
sight of the history vaccines you know
part of the reason I'm able to be here
talking with you is my grandparents did
not die in 1918 during the Spanish flu
when it is estimated 50 million people
done twice as many people's were killed
in combat and World War one died of this
disease if you go to old cemeteries you
can see these tombstones of very young
people died of the flu so people just
lost sight of history and you can we all
tend to go we'll look at the facts
change your mind but it takes people a
couple years to change their minds so my
recommendation Daniel is stick with it
you'll get frustrated the person I get
for us but present the idea of cognitive
dissonance this is my latest idea about
a way to work together to scientific
understanding
[Music]